all right blokes last play let's work  together now eggs you're getting the  ball the rest of you clear a path ready  run eggs lengua a ragged bunch had all  been excluded from military service in  the war for one reason or another they  were tools Franklin flat feet chuckles  Charlie hunchback ISM Billy the snake  rigor mortis Tom and brother Thomas  fizzle nuts  Siamese twins rats O'Reilly he was a  giant rat coach he was too old and  dropped eggs mcdougal 25,000 vision and  the team captain  Mikey Lawson hydrophobia Mikey had such  a strong fear of water he couldn't even  get on the boat to go to the war in  Europe leaves losses again